Speaker 1: So tonight, at least where I am, it's
Speaker 1: evening.
Speaker 1: I want to speak about what it means to live
Speaker 1: on the edge of evolution, on the very edge
Speaker 1: of the creative impulse, and, very
Speaker 1: specifically, I want to try and articulate,
Speaker 1: explicate, define, define, give all of you
Speaker 1: a sense, an idea, a feeling of what a truly
Speaker 1: liberated, inherently creative,
Speaker 1: evolutionary-inspired relationship to the
Speaker 1: human experience actually is.
Speaker 1: This is what I want to try and do, but at
Speaker 1: the very beginning of the presentation I
Speaker 1: wanted to make clear, as I often do, that
Speaker 1: the context in which I teach and all the
Speaker 1: points I'm trying to make about life and
Speaker 1: about reality and about the human
Speaker 1: experience are all from the perspective of
Speaker 1: awakened consciousness or enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness, as I experience it and as I
Speaker 1: understand it.
Speaker 1: So it's a unique vantage point, it's a very
Speaker 1: particular way of seeing reality,
Speaker 1: understanding reality and relating to
Speaker 1: reality.
Speaker 1: But I want to make clear it is not the only
Speaker 1: way to see reality, it's not the only way
Speaker 1: to understand reality and it's not the only
Speaker 1: way to make sense out of reality.
Speaker 1: But it's an important one and what makes
Speaker 1: what I'm defining as the enlightened
Speaker 1: perspective or the enlightened vantage
Speaker 1: point uniquely profound and uniquely
Speaker 1: significant as we try and come to terms
Speaker 1: with what it means to be human, what it
Speaker 1: means to be conscious.
Speaker 1: What it means to be conscious is.
Speaker 1: This is because when we, when we awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, when our
Speaker 1: consciousness expands in the enlightenment
Speaker 1: context, there's a shift in our experience
Speaker 1: of consciousness and cognition from what
Speaker 1: could be called a relative perspective,
Speaker 1: relative understanding, relative
Speaker 1: consciousness and relative cognition to
Speaker 1: absolute consciousness and absolute
Speaker 1: cognition.
Speaker 1: So it's hard to understand what the
Speaker 1: difference between relative and absolute
Speaker 1: actually means, outside of having the
Speaker 1: actual experience of what it means.
Speaker 1: Otherwise, it tends to become way too
Speaker 1: intellectually abstract a distinction.
Speaker 1: But we've got to work with where we are.
Speaker 1: So everybody do the best they can.
Speaker 1: But I just I want to say that when we yes,
Speaker 1: I'd like a two that when we, when we
Speaker 1: consciously choose to embrace the unique
Speaker 1: perspective that becomes available to us
Speaker 1: when we awaken to enlightened awareness,
Speaker 1: the unique perspective that becomes
Speaker 1: available to us when we awaken to
Speaker 1: enlightened awareness, we are choosing to
Speaker 1: embrace a non-relative or absolute position
Speaker 1: in relationship to being human.
Speaker 1: And if we choose to take an absolute
Speaker 1: position in relationship to the challenge
Speaker 1: of being human, it's important that we
Speaker 1: clearly understand that we're doing that
Speaker 1: and we clearly understand that we're doing
Speaker 1: that and we clearly understand that this
Speaker 1: absolute vantage point, this absolute
Speaker 1: perspective, this absolute position is
Speaker 1: realizable.
Speaker 1: It's realizable and it's possible to have
Speaker 1: an experience of what that means, but as a
Speaker 1: human being it's impossible to reach it or
Speaker 1: to equal it.
Speaker 1: This is the absolute position, the absolute
Speaker 1: vantage point which enters into our
Speaker 1: awareness and our understanding in higher
Speaker 1: states of consciousness, when we transcend
Speaker 1: the ego and the small self, reveals to us a
Speaker 1: non-relative or absolute dimension of
Speaker 1: reality which is definitely higher and
Speaker 1: inherently free and liberated in ways that
Speaker 1: relative reality, relative consciousness,
Speaker 1: relative cognition, relative experience
Speaker 1: never is and never will be.
Speaker 1: So as I describe this non-relative or
Speaker 1: absolute vantage point from the perspective
Speaker 1: of the evolutionary impulse, I want you all
Speaker 1: to understand that I'm describing a
Speaker 1: possibility and a potential that is
Speaker 1: ultimately unattainable.
Speaker 1: And a big part of the teaching of
Speaker 1: evolutionary enlightenment which is what I
Speaker 1: teach, is a big theme in this teaching is
Speaker 1: to reach beyond ordinary boundaries as we
Speaker 1: strive to evolve and strive to become more
Speaker 1: conscious and strive to actual more
Speaker 1: conscious and strive to actualize and
Speaker 1: realize and liberate all the inherent
Speaker 1: creative potentials that exist within us.
Speaker 1: But it becomes apparent pretty soon that
Speaker 1: unless we all are willing to make the
Speaker 1: heroic spiritual effort to liberate these
Speaker 1: extraordinary potentials within us that
Speaker 1: we're never going to do it.
Speaker 1: And so I found that, while we reach for
Speaker 1: what I'm defining as being absolute in this
Speaker 1: creative context, we're reaching for a
Speaker 1: possibility we're never going to be able to
Speaker 1: fully attain as long as we're in this human
Speaker 1: body and mind, in this human frame.
Speaker 1: It's in it, through the reaching, that new
Speaker 1: and extraordinary potentials and powers and
Speaker 1: possibilities begin to reveal themselves
Speaker 1: and manifest themselves.
Speaker 1: And they manifest themselves only because
Speaker 1: we were reaching beyond ordinary boundaries,
Speaker 1: which most people don't like to do or not
Speaker 1: in the habit of doing.
Speaker 1: The evolutionary relationship to
Speaker 1: enlightenment is very goal-oriented.
Speaker 1: It's actually about liberating capacities
Speaker 1: of consciousness, cognition and ways of
Speaker 1: seeing reality that we need to reach for
Speaker 1: that they won't just reveal themselves to
Speaker 1: us of their own accord.
Speaker 1: We have to be interested in cracking the
Speaker 1: atom, so to speak, of our own ignorance in
Speaker 1: the context of an evolutionarily inspired
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: It was in the reaching, when we stretch
Speaker 1: beyond the normal boundaries, when we break
Speaker 1: the boundaries of our own multidimensional
Speaker 1: levels of inertia, refusal, resistance,
Speaker 1: ignorance, arrogance, stupidity,
Speaker 1: selfishness and narcissism, that
Speaker 1: extraordinary things begin to reveal
Speaker 1: themselves and become apparent to us that
Speaker 1: we just had no idea existed so, and become
Speaker 1: apparent to us that we just had no idea
Speaker 1: existed.
Speaker 1: So this non-relative or absolute dimension
Speaker 1: of reality reveals to us miraculous
Speaker 1: potentials, and that's what I want to talk
Speaker 1: about Now.
Speaker 1: To continue along these lines, the paradox
Speaker 1: of enlightenment has to do with the fact
Speaker 1: that we're all mortal human beings, so we
Speaker 1: are physically mortal and frail and
Speaker 1: vulnerable.
Speaker 1: We are emotionally, psychologically,
Speaker 1: mortally frail and vulnerable.
Speaker 1: We're all imperfect and we're never going
Speaker 1: to be able to get anywhere near being
Speaker 1: perfect expressions and manifestations of
Speaker 1: the human potential, because it's never
Speaker 1: happened before.
Speaker 1: Perfection exists as an ideal that exists
Speaker 1: somewhere in the distant future and, as
Speaker 1: I've been saying, if we continue to reach
Speaker 1: for perfection, we can realize moments of
Speaker 1: grace and give rise to possibilities that
Speaker 1: are truly miraculous but are not yet truly
Speaker 1: perfect.
Speaker 1: So in this enlightenment process, we are
Speaker 1: trying to straddle two boats.
Speaker 1: One of those boats exists in the
Speaker 1: non-relative or absolute dimension of
Speaker 1: reality and the other boat exists in the
Speaker 1: relative dimension of reality.
Speaker 1: And we want to.
Speaker 1: What we want to do through spiritual
Speaker 1: practice and inquiring and investigation
Speaker 1: and commitment, we want to learn how to
Speaker 1: balance these relative and absolute
Speaker 1: dimensions of reality and learn how to
Speaker 1: balance them exquisitely, elegantly,
Speaker 1: beautifully.
Speaker 1: Some people go too far in either direction
Speaker 1: and make a terrible mistake as they leave
Speaker 1: out one side of the picture.
Speaker 1: So some realizers in the enlightenment
Speaker 1: traditions, when they awaken, they will
Speaker 1: claim that only the absolute is real and
Speaker 1: everything relative, gross and subtle is
Speaker 1: all part of that which is unreal.
Speaker 1: And everything relative, gross and subtle
Speaker 1: is all part of that which is unreal.
Speaker 1: And so in those traditions, using that kind
Speaker 1: of contextual framework, a significant part
Speaker 1: of the experience of being human, which
Speaker 1: exists in relative reality, is somehow
Speaker 1: being avoided and denied and not honestly
Speaker 1: and truthfully being fully embraced and
Speaker 1: responded to.
Speaker 1: I believe I don't think I'm the only one
Speaker 1: who sees it that way.
Speaker 1: And that's one side of the spectrum.
Speaker 1: On the other side of the spectrum there's
Speaker 1: people who deny that any kind of absolute
Speaker 1: or non-relative dimension of reality or
Speaker 1: consciousness actually exists.
Speaker 1: And people speaking from such a vantage
Speaker 1: point would say that that which is purely
Speaker 1: relative is all there is.
Speaker 1: Tragically so, to use mythic language, they
Speaker 1: would proclaim that Gagas really exists, or
Speaker 1: there's no such thing as an absolute
Speaker 1: principle that exists, the discovery which
Speaker 1: changes everything and becomes the source
Speaker 1: of our liberation.
Speaker 1: They would deny it.
Speaker 1: They say it's all a realm of fantasy and
Speaker 1: imagination, religious and spiritual
Speaker 1: fantasy and imagination.
Speaker 1: So what I try and do is I try and do the
Speaker 1: best I can to make clear to everybody, as
Speaker 1: my teacher made clear to me, that relative
Speaker 1: and absolute are two sides of one coin.
Speaker 1: They're two parts of a whole picture of
Speaker 1: reality and have a whole experience of
Speaker 1: reality.
Speaker 1: Relative and absolute are one and not two.
Speaker 1: And the more we understand this, the more
Speaker 1: we make it possible for our experience of
Speaker 1: relative reality to inform our experience
Speaker 1: and understanding of absolute reality.
Speaker 1: And the same way, we want to learn how to
Speaker 1: have our experience of enlightened
Speaker 1: awareness of absolute reality inform our
Speaker 1: experience of relative reality, challenging
Speaker 1: the challenge of being fully human in a
Speaker 1: difficult and challenging world.
Speaker 1: So that's kind of the big picture.
Speaker 1: Now, in my teaching of evolutionary
Speaker 1: enlightenment for many years I've made this
Speaker 1: distinction between what I have chosen to
Speaker 1: call the old enlightenment and the new
Speaker 1: enlightenment, the old enlightenment, or
Speaker 1: what I'm choosing to call the old
Speaker 1: enlightenment and the new enlightenment.
Speaker 1: The old enlightenment, or I'm choosing to
Speaker 1: call the old enlightenment, is the being
Speaker 1: enlightenment.
Speaker 1: It's what the great Eckhart Tolle teaches
Speaker 1: so beautifully.
Speaker 1: It's what the Buddha was pointing to.
Speaker 1: It's the awakening to that which is
Speaker 1: changeless, timeless, formless,
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless and eternal.
Speaker 1: It's about the awakening to what the Buddha
Speaker 1: called the deathless, the uncreated and the
Speaker 1: unborn, what Ramana Maharshi called the
Speaker 1: self, what Mahayana Buddha self referred to
Speaker 1: as the deepest dimension of reality, is
Speaker 1: voidness, emptiness or nothingness.
Speaker 1: So in the traditional, what I call the old
Speaker 1: enlightenment, as we aspire to awaken to
Speaker 1: the enlightenment of the Buddha, of Ramana
Speaker 1: Maharshi, the goal in that context is
Speaker 1: usually the goal in that context is usually
Speaker 1: the goal of freedom, inner freedom of a
Speaker 1: radical, uncompromised, profound, almost
Speaker 1: inconceivable experience, of almost
Speaker 1: inconceivable experience of liberation.
Speaker 1: And the experience of timeless, formless,
Speaker 1: beginningless and endless, eternal
Speaker 1: liberation is definitely not nothing, it's
Speaker 1: definitely something.
Speaker 1: It's definitely not nothing, it's
Speaker 1: We don't want to underestimate the
Speaker 1: significance and the profundity of the
Speaker 1: experience of inner liberation.
Speaker 1: So the experience of inner liberation of
Speaker 1: samadhi, of satori, of nirvana, if you're
Speaker 1: lucky enough to glimpse it, you'll know
Speaker 1: that you'll suddenly understand what the
Speaker 1: Buddha was talking about, you'll suddenly
Speaker 1: understand what Ramana Maharshi was talking
Speaker 1: about.
Speaker 1: It will suddenly all make sense to you and
Speaker 1: it'll never make sense to you unless you
Speaker 1: actually have the experience.
Speaker 1: But the experience is of a primordial.
Speaker 1: It's the discovery of a primordial state of
Speaker 1: being where liberation is all there is.
Speaker 1: There's only freedom.
Speaker 1: And in that miraculous state of
Speaker 1: consciousness you find that that miraculous
Speaker 1: state of freedom not only is your
Speaker 1: birthright but has been available and
Speaker 1: present to you from the very beginning.
Speaker 1: You just didn't see it, you weren't aware
Speaker 1: of it because your attention was on other
Speaker 1: things.
Speaker 1: But in this miraculous state of inner
Speaker 1: freedom, the essence of it is.
Speaker 1: The essence of it reveals itself to us when
Speaker 1: we let go of everything else.
Speaker 1: So the metaphor that I often use for
Speaker 1: letting go of everything, letting go of
Speaker 1: everything else, is having nothing, knowing
Speaker 1: nothing and being no one, zero emptiness.
Speaker 1: So in Buddhism they tell us that the
Speaker 1: experience of profound liberation is
Speaker 1: freedom from attachment and freedom from
Speaker 1: desire.
Speaker 1: Having nothing, knowing nothing and being
Speaker 1: no one is liberation.
Speaker 1: no one is is liberation.
Speaker 1: Having nothing, knowing nothing, being no
Speaker 1: one, is unconditional, radical and profound
Speaker 1: liberation from attachment and longing.
Speaker 1: Having nothing, knowing nothing, being no
Speaker 1: one.
Speaker 1: So the goal in this, what I call the all
Speaker 1: enlightenment, is to, at the level of our
Speaker 1: souls, the level of the soul to have let go
Speaker 1: so deeply that there is an inner access to
Speaker 1: a state of infinite freedom, where there is
Speaker 1: a nothing that is synonymous with eternity.
Speaker 1: And in that nothing that is synonymous with
Speaker 1: eternity there seems to be no such thing as
Speaker 1: birth, no such thing as death, no such
Speaker 1: thing as here, no such thing as there.
Speaker 1: But the idea is, in this kind of primordial,
Speaker 1: traditional enlightenment, the fundamental
Speaker 1: position of that kind of experience is
Speaker 1: being free from I'm free from the mind, I'm
Speaker 1: free from identification with the body.
Speaker 1: I'm free from the mind, I'm free from
Speaker 1: identification with the body, I'm free from
Speaker 1: identification with time, I'm free from
Speaker 1: identification with the world.
Speaker 1: So if you're free from conscious and
Speaker 1: unconscious attachment and if you're free
Speaker 1: from longing for anything else than freedom,
Speaker 1: you're going to be pretty enlightened,
Speaker 1: obviously.
Speaker 1: But there's another kind of enlightenment
Speaker 1: that I want to speak about that relates to
Speaker 1: the subject of this gathering today, which
Speaker 1: is living on the edge of evolution, which
Speaker 1: is living on the edge of evolution.
Speaker 1: So in the context of the inherent
Speaker 1: creativity, it is the manifest expression
Speaker 1: of the evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 1: When we look at enlightenment in the
Speaker 1: context of conscious evolution, we begin to
Speaker 1: see a very different kind of picture,
Speaker 1: because the question in the evolutionary
Speaker 1: context is for you and for me, and for all
Speaker 1: of us that are interested in the subject,
Speaker 1: the question of how free we are can be
Speaker 1: answered.
Speaker 1: And when we subject, the question of how
Speaker 1: free we are can be answered.
Speaker 1: And when we look into the question of how
Speaker 1: free are we, are you and me?
Speaker 1: How free are we?
Speaker 1: How available?
Speaker 1: How available are we to be able to respond
Speaker 1: unconditionally to evolutionary potential?
Speaker 1: How free am I to respond?
Speaker 1: How free are you to respond to the
Speaker 1: recognition and to the revelation of
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential as it appears within
Speaker 1: your heart and mind?
Speaker 1: Are we attached, distracted, busy with
Speaker 1: other things?
Speaker 1: Dug in?
Speaker 1: Is our lives hopelessly dug in, consciously
Speaker 1: and unconsciously, and attached to first
Speaker 1: principles and first values that have
Speaker 1: nothing to do with the inherent creativity
Speaker 1: of the universe?
Speaker 1: Are we knowingly or unknowingly living in
Speaker 1: the past, living in old ideas about the
Speaker 1: meaning and purpose of life that have
Speaker 1: nothing to do with spiritual freedom and
Speaker 1: that have nothing to do with liberating our
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential?
Speaker 1: Because the most beautiful thing about the
Speaker 1: discovery of evolution is that, because
Speaker 1: it's the recognition that the universe,
Speaker 1: that the creative process as a whole, is
Speaker 1: moving.
Speaker 1: It's not static.
Speaker 1: The energy and intelligence that created
Speaker 1: the universe and is creating the universe
Speaker 1: right now is moving.
Speaker 1: It is always becoming more of what it can
Speaker 1: be intimate complexification.
Speaker 1: It's on a journey of self-discovery and
Speaker 1: self-realization, as are all of us.
Speaker 1: So does the picture of reality that we use
Speaker 1: to frame our experience.
Speaker 1: Is the picture of reality that we use to
Speaker 1: frame our experience?
Speaker 1: Is it a moving picture?
Speaker 1: Do we see the reality of the present moment
Speaker 1: emerging out of an evolutionary continuum,
Speaker 1: or do we see ourselves as living in more or
Speaker 1: less a static frame based upon old ideas,
Speaker 1: whether these ideas are personal and
Speaker 1: psychological, related to our own unique
Speaker 1: souls, experience, or do we see ourself and
Speaker 1: our values, the values that we're
Speaker 1: consciously and unconsciously attached to
Speaker 1: and identified with as coming from an
Speaker 1: outdated past, which those values no longer
Speaker 1: are actually relevant anymore?
Speaker 1: What world are we knowingly and unknowingly
Speaker 1: choosing to live in, to be acting from and
Speaker 1: within?
Speaker 1: So, as you awaken to an evolutionary first
Speaker 1: values and first principles, the fact that
Speaker 1: the whole process, the whole universe is
Speaker 1: moving and it's becoming and complexifying
Speaker 1: constantly and there's no such thing as
Speaker 1: anything static in this process, when you
Speaker 1: really let that truth into your soul, when
Speaker 1: you feel, when you get to feel within your
Speaker 1: own consciousness the presence of the
Speaker 1: vibration, the pulsation of the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse of this sense, this
Speaker 1: feeling of movement and reaching towards
Speaker 1: the future, and you see that all of reality
Speaker 1: is moving, nothing is fixed and static.
Speaker 1: And then you realize, in that context, you
Speaker 1: begin to realize, to become aware of the
Speaker 1: fact that, as I've been saying, so many of
Speaker 1: you are and our ideas, beliefs, attachments,
Speaker 1: fixations, fears and desires are all
Speaker 1: emerging in a very static context.
Speaker 1: It's not ultimately real.
Speaker 1: And not only is it not ultimately real, but
Speaker 1: it's not even in alignment with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary becoming of the universe.
Speaker 1: As integral philosophy tells us and makes
Speaker 1: clear to us, the universe has an inside and
Speaker 1: an outside.
Speaker 1: The outside of the universe is matter and
Speaker 1: energy and the universe in the inside of
Speaker 1: the universe is subjectivity and
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: So as the exterior is part of a
Speaker 1: developmental process it's been in progress
Speaker 1: for about 14 billion years it makes perfect
Speaker 1: sense that the inside of the universe, the
Speaker 1: within of all things, has also been on a
Speaker 1: long journey.
Speaker 1: So is our experience of consciousness and
Speaker 1: cognition and is our unique soul living in
Speaker 1: alignment with the evolutionary becoming of
Speaker 1: the cosmos?
Speaker 1: Usually it's not the case.
Speaker 1: How do we see ourselves as unique human
Speaker 1: beings?
Speaker 1: How do we see ourselves in this picture?
Speaker 1: Do we see ourselves experiencing at the
Speaker 1: level of consciousness and cognition and at
Speaker 1: the level of our souls.
Speaker 1: Do we feel that inner momentum of the
Speaker 1: evolving cosmos reaching ever forward into
Speaker 1: the future, trying to give rise to its own
Speaker 1: creativity, leading edge of ensuring our
Speaker 1: potentials?
Speaker 1: Do we feel that movement in ourselves?
Speaker 1: Do we feel ourselves looking towards the
Speaker 1: future, feeling towards the future?
Speaker 1: Do you feel within yourself a feeling
Speaker 1: towards the future and in that feeling
Speaker 1: towards the future a great yearning, great
Speaker 1: ecstatic yearning for what could be?
Speaker 1: And in the context that I wish I'm sharing,
Speaker 1: this yearning for what could be is always
Speaker 1: that which has never existed before.
Speaker 1: It's always a higher and deeper possibility,
Speaker 1: it's always a step forward and a step up, a
Speaker 1: step beyond.
Speaker 1: There's always a reaching, an ecstatic
Speaker 1: reaching for the possible.
Speaker 1: And do you feel this reaching for the
Speaker 1: possible in your body, in your mind, in
Speaker 1: your soul?
Speaker 1: Because in an evolutionarily inspired and
Speaker 1: informed enlightenment, the expression of
Speaker 1: that enlightenment in time and space is the
Speaker 1: liberated.
Speaker 1: Is the liberated liberated willingness and
Speaker 1: ability to respond without hesitation,
Speaker 1: fearlessly, to evolutionary opportunity.
Speaker 1: It means that you're available.
Speaker 1: It means that you're available, it means
Speaker 1: that one is available.
Speaker 1: Most people aren't really very available
Speaker 1: because we're stuck in old paradigms, old
Speaker 1: beliefs, old ways of thinking, feeling,
Speaker 1: desiring, old forms of attachment that
Speaker 1: might have been at the very leading edge or
Speaker 1: cutting edge 500 years ago, 400 years ago,
Speaker 1: 300 years ago, 200 years ago, 100 years ago,
Speaker 1: 50 years ago, maybe even 20 years ago.
Speaker 1: So to live on the very edge of evolution
Speaker 1: means that, means that we've aligned
Speaker 1: ourself with, consciously and deliberately
Speaker 1: chosen to align ourselves so profoundly
Speaker 1: with this evolutionary principle that we
Speaker 1: are spiritually and energetically and
Speaker 1: morally available to respond to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential that reveals itself.
Speaker 1: Evolutionary potential that reveals itself.
Speaker 1: If we're gonna be living on the edge of, if
Speaker 1: we're gonna be living on the very edge of
Speaker 1: evolution, it means we have to be ready to
Speaker 1: respond, and we can only respond if we're
Speaker 1: committed to being ready to respond.
Speaker 1: And if we're going to be ready to respond,
Speaker 1: and if we're going to be ready to respond
Speaker 1: at all, it means that our philosophy, that
Speaker 1: our life philosophy, our personal religious
Speaker 1: impulses, would have to be aligned in a
Speaker 1: profound and significant way with the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse itself.
Speaker 1: And the evolutionary impulse is an
Speaker 1: experience of ecstatic urgency and a
Speaker 1: spiritually palpable feeling of
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential.
Speaker 1: But that's something we have to.
Speaker 1: We have to, we have to, we have to make
Speaker 1: ourselves free.
Speaker 1: But that's something we have to make
Speaker 1: We have to become free so that we will be
Speaker 1: available to respond to the call of
Speaker 1: evolution.
Speaker 1: So there's a distinction I often like to
Speaker 1: make in the teaching of evolutionary
Speaker 1: enlightenment, which I want to briefly
Speaker 1: bring up here because it's a good time to
Speaker 1: do it, and that is in the practice of what
Speaker 1: I was explaining is my definition of the
Speaker 1: traditional enlightenment.
Speaker 1: The being enlightenment, the enlightenment
Speaker 1: of the Buddha, the enlightenment that
Speaker 1: Akartali talks about so beautifully, is the
Speaker 1: way to realize.
Speaker 1: The being enlightenment is usually what
Speaker 1: happens is when you have a realization,
Speaker 1: when you experience a spiritual insight,
Speaker 1: moment of depth, experience, a higher state
Speaker 1: of consciousness, consciousness of being
Speaker 1: timeless, formless, beginningless, endless,
Speaker 1: eternal being, eternal freedom.
Speaker 1: The response to those kinds of experiences
Speaker 1: always is to let go.
Speaker 1: And the more you let go into having nothing,
Speaker 1: knowing nothing and being no one, zero, the
Speaker 1: more freedom you will experience as being.
Speaker 1: So.
Speaker 1: In the being enlightenment it's realize and
Speaker 1: let go, and we find for most of us there's
Speaker 1: always more to let go of.
Speaker 1: Even if you're good at letting go and even
Speaker 1: if you let go of a lot, one finds that in
Speaker 1: most cases there's always more to go.
Speaker 1: So realize and let go is the practice of
Speaker 1: being enlightenment.
Speaker 1: To put it in so realize and let go is the
Speaker 1: practice of being enlightenment.
Speaker 1: To put it in a nutshell realize and let go,
Speaker 1: realize and let go, realize and let go.
Speaker 1: But in the evolutionarily inspired
Speaker 1: enlightenment, the kind of enlightenment
Speaker 1: that reveals itself to us when we awaken to
Speaker 1: the evolutionary impulse, that reveals
Speaker 1: itself to us when we awaken to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse, In evolutionary
Speaker 1: enlightenment and evolutionarily inspired
Speaker 1: enlightenment it's very different than it's
Speaker 1: realize and respond, realize and respond.
Speaker 1: Now, realize and respond.
Speaker 1: So if you in other words it means if you
Speaker 1: realize if in a moment of spiritual
Speaker 1: realization, spiritual insight, you realize
Speaker 1: a great potential that wants to actualize
Speaker 1: itself within you or in the world around
Speaker 1: you, the world that you occupy you realize
Speaker 1: a great potential that wants to actualize
Speaker 1: itself, then what you would do if you were
Speaker 1: free, if you were liberated, would be to,
Speaker 1: without hesitation, respond to what you
Speaker 1: realized.
Speaker 1: You wouldn't wait, you wouldn't hesitate,
Speaker 1: you wouldn't have a cigarette.
Speaker 1: Think about it.
Speaker 1: You take the leap of faith because you'd
Speaker 1: seen what's possible and because you see
Speaker 1: yourself in that context as an instrument
Speaker 1: of evolution in human form.
Speaker 1: You would act immediately, without
Speaker 1: hesitation, with total faith, what you'd
Speaker 1: seen, the more you could do that.
Speaker 1: Then what you see as mere potential
Speaker 1: eventually becomes actualized materially in
Speaker 1: the world that you helped to give rise to
Speaker 1: and co-create through your presence here in
Speaker 1: the world.
Speaker 1: So an evolutionarily inspired enlightenment
Speaker 1: is not realize and let go, it's realize and
Speaker 1: respond.
Speaker 1: So, therefore, to live on the very edge of
Speaker 1: evolution, to live on the edge of evolution
Speaker 1: also implies that we would become agents of
Speaker 1: the actualization of evolutionary potential.
Speaker 1: It would mean that you were spiritually
Speaker 1: prepared, spiritually prepared, spiritually
Speaker 1: equipped to realize and respond when,
Speaker 1: sometime around now-ish.
Speaker 1: Remember enlightenment, whether it's being
Speaker 1: enlightened or revolutionary, enlightenment
Speaker 1: is always about transcending ego.
Speaker 1: Enlightenment, whether it's being
Speaker 1: enlightened or evolutionary enlightenment,
Speaker 1: is always about transcending ego.
Speaker 1: Always just to repeat in case anybody
Speaker 1: wasn't listening enlightenment's always
Speaker 1: about transcending ego.
Speaker 1: So, in evolutionary enlightenment, if you
Speaker 1: realize and respond without hesitating, in
Speaker 1: an act of total faith, your ego has no time
Speaker 1: to interfere with you.
Speaker 1: No, but I, the ego, is very good at
Speaker 1: interfering in the arising of evolutionary
Speaker 1: potential and in the actualization of
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential.
Speaker 1: The ego always has good excuses, good
Speaker 1: reasons, especially if smart people come up
Speaker 1: with very good reasons, very good excuses,
Speaker 1: and the ego will always phrase the excuse
Speaker 1: of the good reason with no, but I.
Speaker 1: So the way it works is if you respond
Speaker 1: immediately, without hesitation, without
Speaker 1: reservation, the ego has no chance to
Speaker 1: interfere.
Speaker 1: And the more, the more you and I and we can
Speaker 1: learn how to respond to life without
Speaker 1: allowing our unenlightened egos to mess the
Speaker 1: whole thing up, which the ego very much
Speaker 1: likes to do we can make some real progress
Speaker 1: Progress in terms of the evolution of
Speaker 1: consciousness, progress in terms of the
Speaker 1: actualization of evolutionary potential,
Speaker 1: progress in relationship to the liberation
Speaker 1: of evolutionary potential.
Speaker 1: When you get really good at this, the
Speaker 1: becoming of the cosmos, the becoming of the
Speaker 1: interior of the cosmos, becomes palpably
Speaker 1: discernible within and between human actors.
Speaker 1: And that's when the show gets very exciting,
Speaker 1: when you go wow, we're really on a journey
Speaker 1: of becoming, aren't we?
Speaker 1: And we're going somewhere.
Speaker 1: Baby, it's happening in us and through us
Speaker 1: and between us.
Speaker 1: What's happening?
Speaker 1: It's the energy and intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe and is creating the
Speaker 1: universe, which means God, she's the only
Speaker 1: one who could have created the universe.
Speaker 1: It's becoming more conscious, more palpably
Speaker 1: present as the only actor that it truly is
Speaker 1: through us.
Speaker 1: And when you see this, when you feel this
Speaker 1: and you know it's true, because it starts
Speaker 1: happening through you, that's when your
Speaker 1: spiritual self-confidence goes through the
Speaker 1: roof.
Speaker 1: Did you realize?
Speaker 1: The energy and intelligence that created
Speaker 1: the universe the evolutionary impulse is
Speaker 1: the spiritual principle that makes all
Speaker 1: things possible is actually at work through
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: You realize that we're not victims of a
Speaker 1: material process, that we're not victims of
Speaker 1: a painful material process, trying to do
Speaker 1: the best we can but failing again and again.
Speaker 1: But at the deepest level we begin to
Speaker 1: recognize what a profound role we actually
Speaker 1: are here to play in the unfolding of this
Speaker 1: inner intelligence that's so present in the
Speaker 1: process, which is normally so invisible to
Speaker 1: us.
Speaker 1: So living on the edge of evolution means we
Speaker 1: are available to actualize what becomes
Speaker 1: apparent to us in our deepest moments of
Speaker 1: self-realization, our states of
Speaker 1: consciousness.
Speaker 1: Because when make-wit creates evolutionary
Speaker 1: momentum, creates the inner momentum, I can
Speaker 1: learn to respond unselfconsciously, without
Speaker 1: fear and doubt to interfere.
Speaker 1: Every time I have an insight that's coming
Speaker 1: from the deepest part of me, my awakened
Speaker 1: soul, the momentum of the possible begins
Speaker 1: to be at work in and through my body and
Speaker 1: mind.
Speaker 1: You become engines of evolution, of
Speaker 1: evolutionary potential, and lord knows, the
Speaker 1: world needs as much of that as possible now
Speaker 1: more than ever.
Speaker 1: So the edge of revolution, the way I'm
Speaker 1: describing doesn't live outside you.
Speaker 1: So a big part of how I would define the new,
Speaker 1: the new enlightenment, is that we need to
Speaker 1: find first we need to do the spiritual work
Speaker 1: to awaken to and discover the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse within our own selves, because it
Speaker 1: exists within you.
Speaker 1: The evolutionary impulse exists within you
Speaker 1: as a palpable vibration and pulsation.
Speaker 1: It's already there.
Speaker 1: You just got to discover it and when you do,
Speaker 1: you're going to get very excited because it
Speaker 1: feels so powerful, so potent, so pregnant
Speaker 1: with creativity and so alive and so full of
Speaker 1: pure positivity.
Speaker 1: The evolutionary impulse as a felt
Speaker 1: experience feels like pure, unabashed,
Speaker 1: uncorrupted, unobstructed, overwhelming
Speaker 1: positivity.
Speaker 1: And what it feels like inside you, inside
Speaker 1: me, feels like suddenly all things are
Speaker 1: possible.
Speaker 1: Not naively so, but it's a liberated
Speaker 1: experience of pure potential.
Speaker 1: And it feels so good because you will
Speaker 1: suddenly feel all things are possible.
Speaker 1: Ego, trauma about experiences, unfortunate
Speaker 1: events, great fear, doubt and cynicism
Speaker 1: about life itself, life itself.
Speaker 1: So many human beings these days, for so
Speaker 1: many reasonable good reasons, are
Speaker 1: consciously and unconsciously seem to be
Speaker 1: convinced that life is not such a good
Speaker 1: thing, to be alive is not such a good thing,
Speaker 1: that a human birth is not a great gift and
Speaker 1: that life and death is full of so many
Speaker 1: problems and that so little is possible.
Speaker 1: People feel this on a personal level
Speaker 1: because they personally had bad experiences
Speaker 1: in the past.
Speaker 1: You can feel very discouraged and depressed
Speaker 1: by human potential in general because of
Speaker 1: what a mess in so many areas we're making.
Speaker 1: So this can lead to willingly or
Speaker 1: unwillingly, consciously or unconsciously,
Speaker 1: a tendency towards nihilism, cynicism and
Speaker 1: doubt.
Speaker 1: And have no doubt that nihilism, cynicism
Speaker 1: and doubt are suicidal tendencies if you're
Speaker 1: actually interested in spiritual awakening
Speaker 1: and enlightenment.
Speaker 1: Most of all, we're all vulnerable.
Speaker 1: We have to be very careful where we spend
Speaker 1: our time with our minds.
Speaker 1: We've got to think about life
Speaker 1: philosophically, ethically, emotionally,
Speaker 1: psychologically and spiritually in ways
Speaker 1: that are very positive and in ways that
Speaker 1: will help us to nurture our own potential
Speaker 1: for liberation.
Speaker 1: So when you awaken to the evolutionary
Speaker 1: potential, you will feel all things are
Speaker 1: possible as a state, as an experience, of a
Speaker 1: state of consciousness.
Speaker 1: It's not that it's going to be easy.
Speaker 1: The experience of the revelation that all
Speaker 1: things are possible doesn't mean all things
Speaker 1: becoming possible is going to be part of an
Speaker 1: easy ride.
Speaker 1: It might be a very hard ride but
Speaker 1: fundamentally know fundamentally you can do
Speaker 1: it and it can be done.
Speaker 1: It's the opposite of cynicism and nihilism
Speaker 1: and doubt.
Speaker 1: There is a you experience a kind of
Speaker 1: conviction, a conviction of the inherent
Speaker 1: goodness of life and of the will to exist
Speaker 1: which is inherent in the universe, inherent
Speaker 1: in the evolutionary impulse.
Speaker 1: If you get to become conscious of that will
Speaker 1: to exist, it is the creative impulse, it is
Speaker 1: the evolutionary impulse and you feel the
Speaker 1: pure positivity that is driving it.
Speaker 1: You start to recognize that that pure
Speaker 1: positivity that's driving the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse is not separate from the very best
Speaker 1: part of who you are, who I am and who we
Speaker 1: all are, and you go, wow really.
Speaker 1: So then you discover that this inherent
Speaker 1: positivity is what's driving this whole
Speaker 1: process in the first place, and a
Speaker 1: materialist will never believe you, but if
Speaker 1: you have the experience you realize that's
Speaker 1: actually true Doesn't mean that life isn't
Speaker 1: hard and tough and full of paradoxes and
Speaker 1: contradictions and pain and suffering.
Speaker 1: I'm not saying that, but I'm saying that
Speaker 1: the energy and intelligence that's driving
Speaker 1: this process, it's a very core of
Speaker 1: everything Inherited.
Speaker 1: It is the kind of positivity that we can't
Speaker 1: even begin to imagine with our minds.
Speaker 1: So the idea is, if we live on the very edge
Speaker 1: of evolution, we want to be in touch with
Speaker 1: that positivity.
Speaker 1: That's not mind created, it's revealed to
Speaker 1: us in spiritual revelation and it's being
Speaker 1: in contact with that kind of positivity
Speaker 1: that gives us the courage to live the
Speaker 1: spiritual life in earnest in a frightened
Speaker 1: and confused and understandably frightened
Speaker 1: and confused world.
Speaker 1: The spiritual life must be lived in earnest,
Speaker 1: which means we really mean it.
Speaker 1: It means we're not afraid to live our
Speaker 1: spiritual values and our convictions in
Speaker 1: public because we realize that for the true
Speaker 1: nature of spirit to be able to reveal
Speaker 1: herself in a disbelieving world, some of us
Speaker 1: have to be willing to bear witness.
Speaker 1: It's not a new idea, but it's actually true.
Speaker 1: It takes courage.
Speaker 1: I can hear myself starting to starting to
Speaker 1: sound like a Christian.
Speaker 1: I'm laughing at myself.
Speaker 1: But we human beings emotionally,
Speaker 1: psychologically, philosophically,
Speaker 1: metaphysically, tend to be very weak.
Speaker 1: Very few of us have the courage or the
Speaker 1: conviction of the strength of character and
Speaker 1: strength at the level of the soul to truly
Speaker 1: stand on our own two feet, independently.
Speaker 1: And it takes courage, in a disbelieving
Speaker 1: modern and postmodern world that is so
Speaker 1: skewed by materialism and narcissism, to
Speaker 1: have the courage to bear witness to real
Speaker 1: depth.
Speaker 1: Just because there's so much narcissism and
Speaker 1: materialism and small-mindedness and
Speaker 1: selfishness and ignorance, doesn't mean
Speaker 1: that depth, beauty and perfection doesn't
Speaker 1: exist at a deeper level it does.
Speaker 1: Just because many people haven't found it
Speaker 1: yet or just stumbled upon it doesn't mean
Speaker 1: it's not there.
Speaker 1: But those of us who have had the good
Speaker 1: fortune and the good karma and the grace
Speaker 1: has stumbled upon that perennial truth
Speaker 1: Sooner or later.
Speaker 1: We have to have the courage to bear witness
Speaker 1: in our own ways, whatever that means being
Speaker 1: different things to different people.
Speaker 1: So living on the edge of evolution means
Speaker 1: all these things and more than anything
Speaker 1: else.
Speaker 1: It means because I have awakened to the
Speaker 1: evolutionary impulse, because I know that
Speaker 1: the absolute principle behind the creative
Speaker 1: process, the energy, intelligence that
Speaker 1: created the universe, the evolutionary
Speaker 1: impulse, is who and what God actually is.
Speaker 1: And that creative impulse, in order to
Speaker 1: create the future at the highest level,
Speaker 1: needs me, needs you, to be available and
Speaker 1: ready to respond.
Speaker 1: Because when we wake up, when you wake up
Speaker 1: to all of this, you realize what's called
Speaker 1: evolutionary non-duality and you begin to
Speaker 1: see how your hands and feet, your heart,
Speaker 1: your eyes and your ears and your mind are
Speaker 1: not your own, but they are the eyes, feet,
Speaker 1: heart, eyes, feet, hands, heart and mind of
Speaker 1: the energy and intelligence that created
Speaker 1: the universe.
Speaker 1: They're not yours.
Speaker 1: The ego is a very small part of a much
Speaker 1: bigger picture.
Speaker 1: The ego is just a.
Speaker 1: The ego is useful because it helps your.
Speaker 1: It makes it possible for you to have a
Speaker 1: frontal self, a frontal personality through
Speaker 1: which that energy and intelligence, that
Speaker 1: creative energy and intelligence, can
Speaker 1: express itself, through a frontal self and
Speaker 1: frontal personality.
Speaker 1: So in that sense the ego is not a problem.
Speaker 1: But the ego becomes a problem when it
Speaker 1: thinks that it's the center of the universe
Speaker 1: and the organizing principle behind all
Speaker 1: this, and it's not.
Speaker 1: Body, mind and soul are here for a reason
Speaker 1: and they're here to participate in the
Speaker 1: evolutionary process as consciously as is
Speaker 1: possible for you, for your unique soul.
Speaker 1: The universe becomes conscious through you
Speaker 1: and the universe becomes conscious through
Speaker 1: me and becomes conscious through us.
Speaker 1: The universe is not inherently conscious
Speaker 1: out there.
Speaker 1: To repeat, the universe is not inherently
Speaker 1: conscious out there.
Speaker 1: The universe is conscious in here, within
Speaker 1: us and between us.
Speaker 1: And the universe can become more conscious
Speaker 1: within us and between us.
Speaker 1: The universe out here can become more
Speaker 1: conscious within us and between us.
Speaker 1: conscious within us and between us if we're
Speaker 1: willing to live the spiritual life in
Speaker 1: earnest, the religious life in earnest.
Speaker 1: The universe out there becomes more
Speaker 1: conscious through us.
Speaker 1: That's a very important principle.
Speaker 1: It's something very important to understand
Speaker 1: in evolutionary enlightenment, in
Speaker 1: evolutionary metaphysics.
Speaker 1: As I understand it, this changes everything.
Speaker 1: It's changed everything.
Speaker 1: For me, it's evolutionary non-duality.
Speaker 1: It's when you come to recognize that
Speaker 1: interiority exists as an inherent fact in
Speaker 1: the cosmos and in nature.
Speaker 1: But as the universe evolves through life
Speaker 1: and the complexification of life, life and
Speaker 1: the complexification of life, the capacity
Speaker 1: for the interior, the interiority of the
Speaker 1: cosmos grows and deepens and complexifies.
Speaker 1: And when you experience the spiritual
Speaker 1: impulse which is the urge to become
Speaker 1: conscious, vibrating and pulsating within
Speaker 1: your own self, that's when you realize the
Speaker 1: universe is trying to become more conscious
Speaker 1: through you.
Speaker 1: So let that hit you.
Speaker 1: The the universe is trying to become more
Speaker 1: conscious through you.
Speaker 1: So let that hit you.
Speaker 1: The universe is really trying to become
Speaker 1: more conscious through you.
Speaker 1: And at that level of evolutionary
Speaker 1: development.
Speaker 1: When you understand that, you know why
Speaker 1: you're here.
Speaker 1: And it's not about your personal life.
Speaker 1: This is not a personal journey, by the way.
Speaker 1: Thank God.
Speaker 1: This is not a personal journey.
Speaker 1: If it was, it really would be only a
Speaker 1: nightmare, wouldn't it?
Speaker 1: So when you realize all these things, you
Speaker 1: wake up from the nightmare of the personal
Speaker 1: life and you realize the cosmos is in fact
Speaker 1: alive and awake to itself and that you and
Speaker 1: me and I, and all of us individually,
Speaker 1: collectively, all have a role to play.
Speaker 1: If we make ourselves available and the
Speaker 1: profundity of the experience of
Speaker 1: consciousness and of being alive is
Speaker 1: realized to the degree to which we
Speaker 1: understand that.
Speaker 1: This is that life is a great adventure,
Speaker 1: full of so much unmanifest potential, and
Speaker 1: actualizing that potential potential and
Speaker 1: actualizing that potential and consciously
Speaker 1: actualizing that potential is what this
Speaker 1: life is all about.
Speaker 1: So living on the edge of evolution means
Speaker 1: that you get that, you get it in your soul
Speaker 1: and you do whatever you need to do to do it.
Speaker 1: That's what living a spiritual life is all
Speaker 1: about in an evolutionary context.
Speaker 1: Now, if you choose to live the spiritual
Speaker 1: life in earnest and if that would mean to
Speaker 1: you living on the edge of evolution, it'll
Speaker 1: have a big effect on the life you're living.
Speaker 1: It'll have a big effect on the life you're
Speaker 1: living Because if that's something you
Speaker 1: choose to do, you'll find you can't live
Speaker 1: your life in the old way anymore, because
Speaker 1: the edge of evolution is a real edge and as
Speaker 1: and living on the edge of evolutionary
Speaker 1: potential is very different than not living
Speaker 1: on the edge.
Speaker 1: Let's put it that way.
Speaker 1: So, even though I'm speaking in a way
Speaker 1: that's using a lot of abstractions, what
Speaker 1: I'm saying also practically has profound
Speaker 1: emotional and psychological and practical
Speaker 1: implications for the way we express and
Speaker 1: manifest the life we're living.
Speaker 1: And the more courage you have, the more
Speaker 1: courage one has to walk closer, sorry, the
Speaker 1: more courage one has to walk a little
Speaker 1: farther out on that ledge, the more
Speaker 1: thrilling is the ride.
Speaker 1: But it doesn't mean that it's not easy, for
Speaker 1: obvious reasons.
Speaker 1: Very good, so I think I'm going to shut up
Speaker 1: now.